foreign
everyone my name is Dr Miller and the
SCP we're going to be looking at today
is scp-3
object class Euclid
special containment procedures
scp-3 is to be maintained at a constant
temperature of no less than 35 degrees
Celsius and ideally kept above 100
degrees Celsius no living multicellular
organisms of category 4 or higher
complexity may be allowed to come into
contact with scp-3
in the event of total power failure if
scp-31 begins to increase its mass
assigned personnel must engage in skin
contact with scp-31 ideally Personnel
may use their body heat to return scp-31
to above the critical temperature
however skin contact must be maintained
even in event of scp-3 reaching
activation temperature lasting at
minimum until scp-31 advances fully to
its second growth stage
Personnel who enter scp-3's containment
area must first be examined for body
parasites of category 4 or higher
complexity and sterilized if such
organisms are present all Personnel who
have come in physical contact with
scp-31 aren't to immediately report for
sterilization afterwards
scp-31 must not be removed from scp-32
except in case of emergency procedures
detailed above and a significant change
in scp-32's roon activity including
pattern frequency or color should be
reported within three hours of
occurrence cessation of Rune activity
must be reported immediately
scp-32 must be supplied with power via
the source designated generator
0039 at all times
description
scp-3 consists of two related components
of separate origin referred to as scp-31
and scp-32
scp-31 appears to be composed of chitin
hair and nails of unknown biology
arranged in a configuration similar to
that of a computer motherboard testing
reveals scp-312 predate earliest known
circuit boards by a factor of thousands
of years
scp-31 is considered sentient but not
actively dangerous except under certain
conditions
scp-31 was found on a stone tablet
scp-32 on which it currently resides the
runes on scp-32 are not part of any
known language and emit pale flickering
light patterns
scp-32 is controlled by a non-biological
internal computer the contents of which
are mostly inaccessible without risk of
damaging scp-3 too scp-32 is capable of
controlled emissions of radiation
including heat light and anomalous
radiation types scp-32 contains an
internal power source of an anomalous
nature which appears to have been losing
power since several centuries before
discovery
it is considered probable that scp-32 is
created for the purpose of containing
scp-3-1 partially interpreted data
recovered from scp-3 II May refer to a
past and or potential future LK class
restructuring event caused by scp-3-1
scp-3 was located by remote viewing team
srv04 beta it appears possible that SRV
4 beta was deliberately contacted by a
CP3 too other organizations have also
been alerted to scp-3's existence
possibly by similar means despite this
activity scp-32 does not appear to be
sentient based on its lack of reaction
to m03 Gloria analysis and procedures
when scp-3 drops below the temperature
of 35 degrees Celsius both components
react
first scp-31 enters a growth State
characterized by an exponential increase
in Mass this growth State consists of
two stages in both stages scp-31
partially fuels its growth by converting
matter around it starting with any
surrounding inorganic material including
atmospheric elements then non-living
organic material including cells of dead
skin hair chitin enamel keratin and
other biological materials
the first stage is always the same as
cp31 will first increase its mass then
take a form similar in shape to an alpha
uroid brittle star of 15 meters in
diameter including what appears to be a
central processor of 3 meters in
diameter it will form sensory organs
that appear to scan its surrounding
environment and will partially convert
the area around it to an unidentified
anomalous substance
scp-32 seems immune from conversion
the second stage describes a growth
alteration which occurs when scp-3 comes
into contact with living organic
material scp-3 appears to template
itself off of the organic material and
will attempt communication with
organisms that match its initial
template or templates
in its second stage scp-31 May pause
slow or change its growth and will also
convert inorganic and non-living organic
elements into functionally similar
structures while anomalously altering
their physical makeup
while growth is consistent in the first
stage and the second stage scp-31's
growth rate is diminished by 20 to 90
percent as long as scp-31 remains in
contact with living organic material the
percentage is determined by the
complexity of the organism or organisms
in contact with scp-31
scp-31 appears to devote a large amount
of processing power to analysis of
living organic material
during each of scp-31's growth stages
scp-32 releases bursts of radiation that
temporarily inhibit
scp-31's growth or reverse this growth
when the temperature of scp-31 rises
above 100 degrees Celsius similar
radiation emissions have been replicated
or recorded via other anomalous means
scp-31's biology has been the subject of
extensive study significant elements
have been identified similar to SCP
scp-1512 and
scp-2756 the latter two of which have no
further confirmed connection with scp-31
and no known connection with each other
and none of which are fully understood
technically even less understood than
scp-3 thanks to the extensive
cross-disciplinary research on the scp-3
object to date no convincing analysis
has been put forward which
satisfactorily explains scp-31's
connection to these SCP objects or
others norad's connection to modern
technology Beyond appearance and
potential mimicry via unknown mechanism
addendum 301
acting on information gathered from
linguistic analysis of scp-32's runes
and comparative data analysis research
team m03 Gloria has managed to establish
a link between scp-3 and for analysis of
its functions scp-31 must now be
considered sentient and is to be kept a
minimum of one kilometers from and the
resulting byproduct at all times
addendum three O2
scp-32's power loss has been exacerbated
by the procedures performed by m03
Gloria on orders of o510 m03 Gloria will
continue procedures
addendum 3 O3
during m03 Gloria procedures
scp-31 doubled its mass and began rapid
structural growth temperature was
immediately returned to 100 degrees
Celsius growth and mass increase of
scp-31 continued for 9 minutes and 9
seconds at which time a sustained
radiation Spike was produced by scp-32
in response scp-31 returned to its
normal state in 3 minutes and 39 seconds
New Growth dissolved into a Dusty
residue which was collected for analysis
both scp-31 and scp-32 ceased all
detectable activity scp-32 did not
resume activity until connected to
external power source scp-32's runes
glowed uniformly gray and did not resume
normal activity for three hours
scp-32 no longer appears to be able to
maintain containment area at a
temperature above 35 degree degrees
Celsius without external power supplied
by generators 3 3 through 9.
addendum 304
the procedure detailed in addendum 303
was repeated and scp-31 again entered a
growth state after 10 minutes and 13
seconds
scp-32 once again produced a sustained
radiation Spike
scp-31's growth stopped for 36 seconds
then it resumed at its previous pace
on quadrupling its mass
scp-31 formed a coherent outer shell and
body after appearing to scan its
environment and partially converting its
environment
scp-31 then breached containment
entering the observation Gallery where
nine members of m03 Gloria were present
on physical contact with the team
members scp-31 encompassed them in
rapidly grown appendages and stopped
growth for 15 minutes
scp-31 then resumed growth and
rearranged the component parts of the
center of its form to the shape of a
three meter tall female humanoid with
peripheral tentacles shifting to extrude
primarily from scp-31's newly formed
hair and spine scp-31 then produced
rudimentary vocalizations in an apparent
initial attempt to communicate with
researchers
foreign
individual approached the compromise
containment area in company of a full
Squad of Agents the individual claimed
to be acting on orders of all 510 and
attempted communication with scp-3-1
following this incident agent Jackson of
m03 Gloria successfully restored power
to scp-32 and activated backup
generators to return the temperature to
100 degrees Celsius
scp-31 returned to its normal state
within 21 minutes and 7 seconds and was
successfully recontained without
incident
all nine members of m03 Gloria affected
by scp-31 were afterwards found to be
physically unharmed with no residual
side effects besides psychological
trauma the converted materials of
scp-3's former containment area did not
dissolve and are now under analysis
addendum 305.
in light of the previous incident o510
was removed from the o5 council by joint
decision of o5 05 and o5 m03 Gloria
procedures have been indefinitely
suspended
special Access program m03 Gloria
required
incident report a21b cycle 8 for
dissemination 205 command and staff
interviewers redacted
present052-5710 and staff
interviewed Dr tilde David Moose m03
Gloria Elite
excerpt 5A
she tried to talk to us we all heard her
voice in our heads in a sort of heart
language we couldn't fully understand
some of the others passed out
immediately I lasted a little longer but
it wasn't because of mental fortitude
it's just that she was trying to tell us
different things
she showed Jones a replay of all the
memories of everything Jones ever felt
anything about all over the course of a
few minutes
she ripped three of the researchers upon
and put them back together unharmed she
doesn't understand human emotion or pain
very much about how we experience the
world
yes I would say the containment
procedures are necessary
listen she wants to remake the world
into a paradise a paradise filtered
through her own alien understanding of
paradise but still a paradise designed
for us for Humanity she would be happy
to make a paradise for any sufficiently
complex organism she comes across first
anything with a complex enough mind to
accept her say a dog or a housefly
if she breaches again we have to be
there first
what would it be like
I don't know she showed us images
not quite images I can see them in my
head but they're not pictures the
closest thing I can think of is what you
see when you close your eyes suddenly
and tightly but brighter and more
complex the images had metallic sounds
associated with them and sensory details
that we don't have the words or concepts
to describe
the whole effect felt like words of some
kind I believe she wanted to see what we
could understand
so she could understand us
she didn't have time to finish analyzing
us
I don't know what would have happened if
she had
this concludes today's lecture thank you
for listening if indeed you still are
and you were all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Timothy
anvil zargaron
Professor Puffer
nobody
well remember
vinyl
gavios the hollow
zazapan
Jordan C Wilde
Lemke
Dr Briggs
tailored printers
signor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Gabriel Hawkins
Lost Boy
a real American Hebrew
the Morrigan
James Saba
and NJ vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you